Good afternoon. In compliance with
chapter 551 of the Open Meetings Act of
the Texas Government Code, I call to
order a voting meeting of the Public
Facility Corporation Board of Directors
of the Austin Independent School
District for Tuesday, October 7th, 2025
at 5:34 p.m. A quorum of the board is
physically present at the AISD central
office to conduct this meeting. This
meeting is being broadcast on cable
channel 22 from spectrum sp pardon me
through spectrum a sound broadband and
on channel 99 through entiverse.
Closed captioning in English is
available on these platforms for
individuals who are deaf or heart of
hearing. Thank you for joining us. We
will move to the approval of the agenda.
Secretary Boswell, do you have a motion
to approve the agenda?
>> So moved.
>> Secretary Boswell, thank you so much. Is
there a second?
A second. Thank you, Director Alfiso. I
h having a motion by um Secretary
Boswell and a second by Director Aiso to
approve the agenda. All those in favor,
please raise your right hand.
Excellent. Thank you. The motion passes
unanimously with a vote of four in favor
by all those on the dis.
at our last well before we begin let me
just say welcome and then we'll we'll
keep moving. I would like to welcome uh
the expansion of our board. We have
director uh Alfiso and director Tovar.
Thank you so much for being willing to
uh sacrifice your time to come and
support uh Austin ISD's PFC and the work
that we hope to do for our community.
Thank you so much.
At our last PFC meeting, we voted to
appoint two individuals to serve on the
AISD public facility corporation board
of directors. And I have now introduced
them. So, welcome. Uh, number two, we
will now move on to the action item on
the agenda. Secretary Boswell, do we
have a motion to approve agenda item
2.1? Yes. I move to approve item two 2.1
May 22nd, 2025 public facility
corporation regular voting meeting
minutes. Is there a second?
>> I second.
>> Thank you. Directors, any questions or
comments?
>> None.
So this is the
action on moving forward at Anita Koi
with the um I don't have the agenda in
front of me.
>> We're voting on the minutes.
>> The minutes. Okay. Just want to make
sure.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. No, no discussion.
>> Okay. Perfect. Um, having a motion by
Secretary Boswell and a second by
Director Tovar to approve item 2.1 May
22nd, 2025 public facility corporation
regular voting meeting minutes. All
those in favor, please raise your right
hand.
Okay, the motion passes with four in
favor. Secretary Boswell, do we have a
motion to approve agenda item 2.2?
Yes. I move to approve item 2.2, August
21st, 2025, public facility corporation
regular voting meeting minutes.
>> Is there a second?
>> Second.
>> Excellent. Thank you. Having a motion by
Secretary Boswell and a second by
Director Afiso to approve item 2.2,
August 21st, 2025 public facility
corporation regular voting meeting
minutes. All those in favor, please
raise your right hand.
The motion passes with four in favor.
Before we move on to the final action
item on the agenda, we have Summer
Greathouse, our PFC legal council
joining us today to provide a brief
introduction for our new members. And
after that, I'd like to invite Nick
Walsh from the NRP group to give a
presentation on the phases of the
repurposing of the Anita Koi facility.
Mrs. Greyhouse.
Good afternoon. Um, I think we could
probably go ahead and have Nick come up
now as well. And so then that way we can
just kind of roll from my presentation
directly into his. So what I'll do is
I'll give just a really brief overview
of the PFC and then a brief overview of
the project and then he can go a little
more in depth into the project.
Okay. So um just want to give for our
new uh board members just a very brief
overview. I think in the future we would
love to do a workshop to talk through um
you know some of the the tools that are
available to you and the PFC but for
right now just a very brief overview of
the public facility corporation. So, it
is a nonprofit uh corporation that was
created on behalf of the independent
school district to act on behalf of the
independent school district for the
purposes of financing and constructing
and developing public facilities. And
one public facility uh type that that
the PFC can engage in is the development
of multifamily residential housing. And
that's what we're here today to talk
about with the Anita Koi project. Um I
think something that it's important to
think about is that you know this is a
separate legal entity. This is not the
school district. This is a separate
entity. So there is um you know in terms
of liabilities they are separated. Um in
terms of action right that's why we have
a separate board here and you guys are
here to to help with um taking those
actions. Um, additionally, uh, when the
PFC enters into public private
partnerships with developers, um, that
are private entities, we always ask that
the developers procure insurance on
behalf of the public facility
corporation and that they indemnify the
public facility corporation for any
losses or liabilities that can happen in
connection with these public private
partnerships.
There's a lot of different types of
deals that public facility corporations
can do. Um, one of which is a what's
called either workforce housing or mixed
income development. That's what we're
here today talking about. The only
subsidy for these types of pro uh
projects is a property tax exemption. It
doesn't receive any other subsidies from
the state or from the federal
government. And so I think that's
something important also to think about
here today with this particular project.
Um, and with that, if if there are any
other questions kind of generally about
the public facility corporation, I'll
kind of jump into the Anita Koy project,
just to give an overview and remind the
board of the terms that we have
negotiated and the public benefits that
we have um been able to get the
developer to agree to. If if there's any
just general questions about public
facility corporations, I can get we'll
get really into the weeds the next time
around. I didn't want to make there be
too much this time, but um if you have
any general questions, I'm happy to
answer.
Okay, perfect. Okay, so we'll move on to
talking about um uh Anita Koy. So, um
this project um obviously has been
around for a while. Um, and I'll let
Nick kind of go through the the history
of it, but just for you guys to have um
the especially for the purpose of the
new board members, the economic returns
to the public facility corporation um
are as follows. A $250,000 closing fee,
and this is just we're just talking
about the east phase. There's an east
phase and a west phase. So, $250,000
closing fee, um 10% of the sales tax
savings. The PE the public facility
corporation will be acting as a general
contractor so that the project can
benefit from a sales tax exemption. So,
you guys will receive 10% of that
savings as a payment. Um an annual
payment of $25,000 per year plus 15% of
the property taxes that would have been
paid on the project if it was not
taxexempt.
Um, additionally, upon any refinancing,
15% of the net proceeds of that
refinancing and on any sale, 1% of the
gross sales price. So, each time the
project is sold, you guys will receive
these uh that that fee. Um,
some other uh things that we were able
to get negotiated, there's um land
that's been reserved for um an
alternative learning center. So the
school district will have um still some
school district activities within this
site. Um there is a right of first offer
in favor of the public facility
corporation. So if the project is going
to be sold, the public facility
corporation has the opportunity to
purchase the project back. Um it will be
for fair market value. So it's going to
be a lot of money probably, but and you
would be foregoing any of your fees,
right, if that was to happen. Um other
items that were negotiated is um you
know a parking garage um and uh
increased density for this site. Um
there is a nonprofit space that I
believe is planned to be occupied by DoS
Huntos. Um and that will be uh the PFC
will have the opportunity to have say so
and who goes into that space even if Do
Huntos was to leave. So, that's a a
great community benefit there and having
that space that the developer is
building for you all. Um, the developer
also is going to comply with your
minority and women business enterprises
policy. So, that's 20% of all of the
subcontractors in this project are going
to be um minority and women businesses.
There's going to be a public park with
some green space that'll be managed and
maintained by the developer. There's
tree preservation on the property. There
are maintenance obligations that will be
enforceable by the public facility
corporation. So each seven year each
seven-year interval, the um developer
will have to do a maintenance um public
a physical needs assessment and then
update with any maintenance that needs
to be done as a result of that. And that
will allow the property to be a
well-maintained project so we don't have
an issue of it, you know, becoming
rundown or um having issues with, you
know, safety or, you know, health
issues. Um there's also an ability for
you all to remove the property
management company if they're not doing
a good job and those that's outlined in
all of our documents. Um the Texas
Department of Housing and Community
Affairs will also be uh maintaining um a
a file on this project. There will be
annual compliance moni monitoring
reports that will be due. Um, another
item that I think was really important
to the board when we started talking
about this was the um, advanced
marketing to teachers and there will be
a list that is maintained by the school
district that the developer will use in
terms of, you know, targeting potential
new tenants. And so that will help with
the the um providing housing for
teachers and other folks who work for
the school district. Additionally, the
there is an emphasis on familysiz units
here, three-bedroom and two-bedroom
units. There are no studio apartments in
this uh in this development. Um so that
again goes to the idea of, you know,
having housing for students and folks
with families. There's a guaranteed 40
years of affordability here, which is
the same as low-income housing tax
credit projects. A lot of PFC's um
around the state don't do that. For
example, um the Austin Housing Authority
doesn't do that. So, but you guys are
doing that and that is um I think a
really big benefit for the community. Um
and that is it. So, those are all kind
of that's a it's a lot, but those are
the terms that we were able to negotiate
on um that are, you know, community
benefit and benefit to the school
district.
>> And I'll let Nick go into it from here.
>> Sure. Um well, thank you um President
Hunter and Secretary Boswell and you
know, of course, special welcome to our
new board members and also good to see
you as well. Um very excited to be back
for what is the uh final approval. Can
you guys hear me? Okay. Um the final
approval for east. And so as you know
this this project has been split into
two phases, east and west. Um so I think
it was literally a year ago when we
finalized every everything that summer
just went into. We finalized the term
sheets for east and west. Since then,
we've been we've spent the last year
actually going through the permitting
process with the city of Austin um
clearing those hurdles as well as uh
locking in capital partners for this
transaction. And so the first phase is
ready. We're we are shovel ready. We are
about one and a half months out from
putting a shovel in the ground on the
first phase. And then we'll come back in
um probably four to six months for West
and it will be a phase development.
they'll move right from the one into the
other. But I'm going to briefly go
through just the presentation um which
should be on your screen and then we can
get into questions. Um so again tonight
is for Anita East. As a reminder, you
know, the development team is, you know,
myself, Nick Walsh from the NRP group,
but then we also have, of course, our
architect firm, which is Hatch Oland,
Owen, our Moscow Turo with public art
and placekeeping, Sana public relations,
as well as our co-developer of uh
structure development. So, that is the
team on the developer side. And then
your team on the PFC side, uh you're
being represented by Bracewell as your
PFC council as well as the team from
Kushman and Wakefield um on the real
estate side who's also in the room here
tonight and Jeremy from the public.
[laughter]
So this is the overall timeline from the
last couple years. I think as many of
you know, especially uh you know our
board member here, Mr. Tovar. Uh this
this has been going on for a long long
time. Uh the community has been very
very involved in this site for a very
very long time. But our involvement as a
development team really started when the
trustees voted to the AISD trustees
voted to put out a request for proposals
that was issued uh summer of 2023.
Um that was there was an interview
process. There was, you know, several
rounds of that and ultimately NRP was
selected as the master developer for the
property. Um, and that was officially
approved by the board of trustees in
November 2023. So that officially began
my journey with this project. So we are
going on almost two years now and in
almost two years to the date of that
November approval, we will be officially
closing on the first phase of the
transaction. So very excited. Um, but
what's happened since there? So starting
in 2024
that began the resoning process that was
that took nearly a year to go through
the resoning and community sorry the
neighborhood plan amendment. Um there
was also due diligence efforts that
began at that time. So this site is
extremely challenging. There is city of
Austin atlas 14 flood plane that had to
be studied. Um there was beautiful,
beautiful trees all across the site
which took immense coordination because
we weren't trying to get rid of nor are
you even allowed to get rid of a lot of
those heritage trees. So trying to work
around them, preserve them but still get
the density that this board asked us to
pro to provide. So that took that was
really the first year. So that was all
of 2024 and then we came back again in
in fall of 2024 and that that is when
the this board the you know the the PFC
board did go ahead and finalize and lock
in the term sheets for both phases which
then allowed us to go and actually
design it. So that began the process of
formal um you know construction plans
working with our architects and our
engineers working with the city of
Austin. Um it's been it's very
challenging site. It's a very urban um
dense site. Again, a lot of trees, a lot
of things to work around. It's I'm not
going to lie, it's been probably the
most challenging site I've ever had in
terms of working with the city of
Austin, working with development
services to come to the final plans and
to negotiate everything that needed to
take place. But we will be permit ready
here and our site development plan will
be complete within the next handful of
weeks. So, we are super excited and
that's what we I've spent this year um
working on leading up until to tonight.
Um at the same time, we also have gone
out and procured our capital partners,
which I'll uh get into in a moment. And
so, following tonight, we will close
hopefully in um before Thanksgiving. We
are set for November 20th. And within a
handful of weeks, the construction team
will mobilize to the property and
actually begin new construction. Um, I
would be remiss if I if I forgot to
mention we actually began starting in uh
June or sorry, starting at the end of
June, start of July, we actually began
the environmental remediation at the
property. And so this has actually been
um much more significant and and and
timely than I think we we thought going
in. This is a large facility um you
know, first built in the 1950s and later
on expanded. So there was a lot of
asbestous asbestous containing
materials. Um there was also other
hazardous materials. You know, think
about certain light bulbs, thermometers,
things like that that you can't just
take to a landfill. They actually had to
be removed, classified, and taken to
very specific landfills. So for the last
90 days, we've had um a remediation
contractor at the property. Um you know,
it's all over it's overseen through a
licensed environmental remediation
expert. There's closeout reports
involves the TCQ and it's been very
intense but that process has been going
on for over 90 days now and we are
transitioning then once that is complete
demolition is actually beginning. I
think it will be beginning as early as
this week. So, the existing facility,
now that the environmental remediation's
been addressed, the demolition will
begin. And so, hopefully when we go
ahead and begin uh when we close in late
November, we should hopefully have a
shovel ready site and all of that
demolition and remedi remediation
activities should be complete.
Okay. So summer kind of hit on a lot of
this, but you know through the years
whether it was through the board of
trustees, through community engagement
that have been done by AISTD, through
community engagement by NRP, these were
kind of the eight more or less goals
that really stuck out that really led to
where we were. And so this is was what
you guys gave me. This is the same slide
actually from a year ago, but I wanted
to give you an update on where we landed
on everything now that we're almost
putting a shovel in the ground. So, you
know, the first and foremost, you know,
designing for neighborhood harmony, that
was a big thing we heard through the
resoning process. There was a lot of
concern with potential height at the
property. The zoning allowed for up to
90 ft. Uh and and so working with the
community, we actually respected even
though they no longer were in place
residential setbacks. And so where we're
approximate to single family housing, it
the property the project is both
projects are only four stories. And so
that's something that at y'all's
request, we we did make those changes.
Um and in total where we have limited
ourselves to 60 ft, which the community
was frankly thrilled to hear, especially
in our follow-up meetings and especially
knowing that um we had that ability to
go up to 90. But we did hearing you all,
hearing the community, we limited
ourselves and we were still able to get
significant density at the property. So
that was really really important.
Another thing and and um are we sorry we
board members? We're not trustees. What
are we
>> directors? Director Boswell or Secretary
Boswell I guess. You know you really
push us on not well the whole board did
on familysiz units. um you know anytime
we build a market rate or mixed income
property and you can look at our website
you can look at anything else we've done
in Austin studios onebedrooms and some
two bedrooms and you guys said that's
not good enough and that's not going to
work um and so where we ended up of
course as some mentioned no studios
and multi-unit
floor plan types two and three bedrooms
approximately 45% of units so typically
that would be less than 20%. Um, and so
we have more than double here and
threebedrooms. You guys were like, "Give
me more threebedroom." I think that was
you, President Hunter, who said, "Why
can't we have more?" And I said, "We'll
go find more corners and we'll go create
more corners in the building so that we
can fit those bedrooms into those
units." And so, um, within a quarter
mile of this property, there are
something like 10,000 multif family
units and I think there's all of six to
10 three-bedroom units. this property
alone the east alone has I think 22 west
also has similar so we're going to have
close to 50 three threebedroom homes
right units these are homes for families
that will be in this property but it was
you secretary Boswell who said it's not
just the units it's what about amenities
what about services for families and so
that was one of the things we went back
to after the meeting last year this pro
this east phase will have a um
playground for children um there's also
within the the gym um the the fitness
center there's going to be a children's
playroom so that with a window so you
know you can have a parent running on
the treadmill and you know looking in
the mirror and seeing their their child
you know within the the playroom so
there was things like that we went back
to the drawing board these are not
things we do at our market rate or mixed
income properties um so it was we had to
really kind of figure out how to make it
work and push the design team but it it
did get incorporated so thank you for
that feedback um you know but these
other things you know ensuring financial
potential you know viability um you know
maximizing kind of the number of units
you know in total between the two
phases. Now the the final official
number is 675 units will be delivered
between the two phases. um a lot more
dense than probably what we would have
liked to have done. Frankly, you know,
this is this is expensive four and
fivetory
structured parking wrap style
development and and it was very, you
know, it's very expensive. It's very
challenging to build,
but we got more units and we're going to
be delivering more units the housing
stock and I think ultimately it's going
to be better for the community. Um uh
you know, retaining land for future AISD
use. So, we do have that retained parcel
that uh AIST will be able to use for
whatever future use they may deem
necessary. And so, the trustees at some
point, you know, y'all will be able to
look at that. That's something that you
get to keep another arrow in your
quiver. Um community amenities, of
course, there's the green space that is
going to be preserved as part of this.
Um that will be open to the public. And
in addition to the green space that we
knew, we also incorporated a pocket park
at the southeast corner of the site. So
that's at the corner of Shady and
Gonzalez. Beautiful Pan Grove that
currently exists there. Um if you're
ever like in the neighborhood like
people will walk their dogs in that
area. It's it's it's you know it's
already kind of being used in that sense
but instead of fencing it off as a
private amenity for the residents. We're
actually we built we're building paths
through the Pan Grove. We also want to
incorporate some sort of sculptural art
things like that. So that will be a
public park that is locked in as part of
this in perpetuity. So, in addition to
the green space on the other side of the
sign, pocket park at the corner, it's
really going to be the front entrance to
to the project. Uh, the nonprofit space
as Summer already mentioned, uh, we we
have been working with Totos, of course,
you know, there's no lease sign. They
are the intended user. They helped us to
design the space. So, it is designed
with classrooms, um, you know, office
space, a lobby, a computer lab, um, you
know, restroom facilities, a break room,
things like that. So that space, it's
about 5,000 square feet, is being built
out at no expense to the end user and
will be rented out at zero dollars in
rent. They will any sort of common
charges, their utilities, things like
that, they would be responsible for. So
that is our intended user and and I hope
that does work out. Of course, you know,
the the space won't be built for another
two years, so anything could happen in
that time. But as part of our, you know,
lease agreement that's going to be
locked in that that is will remain as a
communitydriven, community-f facing
public space, nonprofit use, no rent
charge, whatever. Um, so that is the
intention for that space. Um, and then
public art and placekeeping. really
working with Moscow. We're going to, you
know, there's things within the
clubhouse and within, you know, within
the amenity spaces that are really
drawing inspiration from the existing
facility in the community, but there's
also going to be things like murals and
hopefully sculptures in that park and
things like that that we're going to
continue to incorporate. So, really
excited about all these goals. We we
really did our best to listen, go back
to the drawing board where you asked me
to and incorporate all of those items.
So, this isn't a pretty site plan by any
means. is black and white but you know
this is um again where it ended up. So
we tonight are just talking about east
uh which is on the right side of the
screen that is the first phase um that
pocket park I was talking about is in
that southeast corner um the green space
this this northeast corner is that
retained land by the district for
potential future use and in a couple
months we'll come back to talk about
west which is going to be over here on
the left side of the screen.
Um just briefly, you know, I think you
guys know this, but I mean this is I
mean it's nearly a $100 million private
investment of capital for this first
phase. Um so we were able to go out, you
know, your real estate advisors could
tell you, you know, how challenging of a
market this is right now. Um being able
to and in fact, you know, the numbers of
construction starts within the Austin
area. I I will tell you from NRP alone,
we have other proposed projects both
market rate, affordable and public
private partnerships in other areas of
the city that we have not been able to
capitalize um at all and you know that
we've you know are ready to go. It's
been very challenging due to the supply
situation. I personally think that's
temporary. I I believe that all of those
units are being absorbed in in people,
you know, and you've seen a unique thing
about Austin that you've not seen in
other urban areas where rents have
actually decreased, which has proven
what we yell from the rooftops all the
time, which is that if you build the
units, if you continue to build at the
scale that is necessary for the
population growth that has come here,
but also continues to move here, that it
can actually impact rents and it can
impact the housing affordability. from a
market standpoint. So that being said,
that makes it challenging to build new
things because banks and investors are
looking for where is their best bet for
their money. So it was challenging and
especially a project of this size um you
know approaching $und00 million that is
a fat check that they had right but we
were able to negotiate and come to terms
with two capital partners here. So the
the investor limited partner is Clarion
Partners. They're a huge multinational
real estate investment trust. They're
actually investing through their
opportunity zone fund. So, this census
tract is an opportunity zone, which
means there's addition added benefits um
for th the those investors. And so, they
were really interested and willing to
participate because of that added
benefit that was enough to get them over
the hump. Um so, they intend to be at
long-term owner investor in this
property. They have no intent of getting
their money out because the benefit to
them is through that long-term
ownership. And and they've pushed us to
ensure because, you know, and we have
the same mentality, but they've pushed
us to ensure since they're longtime
owners, they want to make sure that we
are only, you know, specking the best
construction, the best materials, things
that are going to hold up. And they were
also very happy to learn of the terms
that you all negotiated which include
that every seven years that report is
getting produced and being enacted to
ensure that the property is being up you
know up upkept and then Goldman Sachs is
going to be uh the construction lender.
So they'll be providing the construction
loan and that is actually through their
urban investment group where because of
the affordable um you know having half
the units rent and income restricted.
They uh have a fund that is actually
dedicated to those types of projects
where there's more than just the real
estate. There's actually that added
benefit as well. So they were very happy
to come on board and partake in this
project as well. Um so those are our
financial partners. Um, and then
ultimately since the where we were last
October, we actually squeezed out two
additional units. So, surprise, you're
welcome. I don't know. Uh, so we went
from 339 uh to 341 in the final design.
Um, again, that mix between 1, two, and
three bedroom types. Highly unusual. No
studios. That makes it 60 and 80%. Half
the units are uh rent and income
restricted. Half are market rate. again
that subsidi the market rate units
subsidize the uh rent and income
restricted uh units at the property. Um
and then you know housing choice
vouchers are accepted. That's something
that is really important if you guys
know about that program. You know
sometimes one of the most challenging
things for the you know families who
receive that assistance is actually
finding properties that accept it. Well,
we are legally bound to through our
partnership and now through state law
and it's something that we actually have
at other properties in Austin, elsewhere
in the state where we have been able to
house those families in these types of
partnerships. So, that that conclude I
have a ton of things in the appendix,
you know, if we want to get into it. I
know I've already been talking for a
while. I I'm happy to jump into any
questions. summer.
>> I just have [snorts] one thing to add
that um Nick's slide um with respect to
the housing choice vouchers prompted me
and I again I know the existing board
members we've had these conversations
but for the benefit of the new board
members. So Nick mentioned that state
law now requires housing choice vouchers
to be accepted at um fac at these types
of projects where a public facility
corporation is involved. Additionally,
there are tenant protections that are
required by law. And so, for example, um
there's uh only certain instances where
tenants can be evicted or their leases
are can be non-renewed. And so, there is
a lot of built-in protection here via
the statute that I didn't really go over
here, but I think that is something
that, you know, is really important and
that is only possible through your
participation in this project.
Thank you so much. So good. Um I loved
it all. Thank you. It was a good update
for us. Um directors, are there any
questions or comments?
>> Yeah, thank you. Um it's [clears throat]
really great to be here.
I mean, the these conversations started
in 2013
and
yeah, that was a while ago. That was
about two or three hairlines ago. It was
more maybe.
So, I do want to applaud um
Superintendent Sigura for your support
in making this happen.
um
public uh attendee Jeremy, I don't want
to say your last name wrong, but you've
been awesome um over the years. And
Nick, you've been available by cell
phone, you know, whenever I've needed to
talk so and check in. So, I really
appreciate all of your support and you
know, to the trustees who helped make
this happen as well. um and for the
trustees who have been on the board of
directors for a while here already
getting this going. So, thank you.
I do think
I do think that the
you know, I can hear people talking to
me right now, you know, saying from the
community saying, um, well, I guess
we'll get into it later when we talk
about MFI. We're gonna talk about that
later. The the percentages or should I
>> please go ahead.
>> Okay. Um
and I checked in with trustees and uh
excuse [clears throat] me, Summer
earlier. I'm new to you. I just met you,
Summer. I'm sorry. I don't even know
your last name. Um but thank you. And I
think it would be good to explain to the
community about how
we're a little bit locked in. we are
pretty much locked in to the percentages
around MFI for the different units. Um
maybe even a quick explanation of like
what MFI is. I'm just thinking people,
>> you know, I want I want like
>> absolutely
>> to be transparent as possible.
>> Uh what the current MFI is. Yeah, we all
know that changes, but like even just
what that would look like currently. Um,
and then what it would mean if we we
were to try to negotiate that or, you
know, change that now. Um, but and I
know you all we just had that
conversation before we started. So,
thank you.
>> No, great question. I and I'll start
with it. Um, Director Tovar, uh, so
[gasps]
the the current affordability at the
project and and what it's intended to be
is the 10% at 60% of the MFI and and 40%
at 80%. And so that is the under chapter
303 of the, you know, of the local
government code. Those that is the
affordability that's prescribed within
statute. Now, that doesn't mean you
can't you couldn't go above it, um, if
that's what this board had, you know,
wanted to do. And so just to take you
through, there was a lot of
conversations, a lot of back and forth,
and even in the RFP process, there was a
lot of back and forth. And part of the
concern in how we what we spent
a lot of time in 2024 before going
coming to the board last October when we
signed the term sheets leading up to
that, there had been a housing survey
done um a handful of years ago, but we
realized to really lock in on the
affordability, there needed to be a
subsequent study. And so working with um
some former staff members of the
district and others, we were able to
send out a much more detailed survey um
specifically trying to reach teachers
and staff members of the district to
ascertain. We we know what their salary
is. I mean the salary is published. I
mean anyone could pull up the salary for
a starting teacher and so on and so
forth. We don't necessarily know the
household makeup and if there was other
income earners within the household. And
so we were able to actually send out a
very detailed survey. I mean, it wasn't
a scientific study by any means, but we
did have, I think, somewhere in the
ballpark of about a thousand folks
respond to that survey. And and based on
that data, you know, there was a lot of
work to crunch the numbers and actually
see where do teachers and staff members
of the district fall. And and that was
one of the the challenges of of the
district forming a PFC and using their
asset which is this property. You know
there are you know I partner with the
housing authority. I partner with the
Travis County Housing Authority
Strategic HFC. There's other entities
that do LITC and do deeply affordable
housing and public housing. But the
district really approached this or at
the time the conversation was about
approaching this. How can we best serve
and prioritize income levels that will
serve our teachers and staff members?
And so the results of that survey when
factoring in if there was an maybe
perhaps a second job or something in the
summertime or a second income earner or
if there were children in the household.
When we were able to actually crunch
those numbers, the results were that the
vast majority, it was somewhere in the
80 80% range of the respondents fell
between 70 and 110% of the AMI. And so
when thinking about the affordability at
the property and where those units were
reserved,
good the minimum the the state the state
minimum of the 10% at 60% of the AMI is
where that landed. And and I'll tell you
today where the Austin single person 60%
AMI is it falls below the starting
salary for a new year one AISTD teacher.
Um [clears throat] and so that you know
the conversations at the time with staff
and and with the with the um directors
at the time is really what led to where
the affordability was. But also that
that was from the you know straight up
from the conversation about how to best
serve teachers and staff. But then there
was the conversation around the
financial viability of the property
which is do we want more things? Do we
want thing do we want to do a nonprofit
space or do we want to have this? And so
there was a lot of conversations because
there was a lot of other items too that
maybe were originally part of the you
know wants list that ended up falling
off as we made hard decisions as this
came to be. But and I'll let summer talk
but that that's basically the summary of
really over the last two years. And then
at the at that meeting in October of
2024, that's when the term sheets for
these two phases were locked in. Um, and
that's what we were able to go and
design off of, you know, and build
construction plans and sign up capital
partners off of those terms uh that were
approved uh this past October.
Summer, if I may, before you begin, part
of uh directors Tovar's question was
really important and um he's still in my
lines, you know, like I always say, make
it plain. I'm going to have to get new
lines, but he asked about um to tell us
what MFI was, AMI, and then how that
changes annually. Um and I always run to
the Travis County to see what it is. I'm
not moving, but I just always want to
know what it is. And I think that that's
people should go back and choose to
watch this. I don't think they will, but
if they do, they will have that
explanation embedded. A
>> absolutely. Oh, sorry. I don't know if
those for me are somewhere.
>> Well, I don't think it matters. Either
one of us could probably
>> probably say it. What's What does it
stand for? [laughter]
>> So, um, AMI is area median income. Also,
AMFI area meeting family income, right?
And so, what that is, it's published by
HUD, um, annually, typically in April.
And, um, we're required by statute to
use the HUD published AMI um, to in for
uh, purposes of PFC partnerships. And as
Nick mentioned, um, this project 10% at
60% of AMI and 40% at 80% of AMI, which
is the statuto minimum for these types
of projects. So what I have, I believe
this is from last year. So just to give
you an idea of what those numbers
because it's percentages, right? Like
who knows what that actually is in terms
of dollars for a a single person at 60%
of AMI, 52,920.
And I I think that I believe these
numbers are last year's numbers. And 80%
of AMI is 70,560.
So, and then for a family of four, for
example, 60% AMI is $75,600
and at 80% of AMI it's $100,800.
And then so that that's these units are
both income restricted and rent
restricted. And what that means is it's
income restricted. So you have to
qualify. That's what we just talked
about is the income level. So, you have
to make that level of income or less to
qualify for those units that are
reserved for either the 60% or the 80%
AMI um families.
But additionally, and this is something
that PFC's were were uh criticized for
back in the day before the law changed
in 2023, was that there was no
requirement for rent restriction under
the law. So, you could be an 80% AMI
person living in a unit but paying
market rent. And so you weren't really
realizing a benefit. Not all PFCs were
doing that. Many of them were already um
rent restricting. So the the rents are
capped. And so the numbers that I have
here again, which I believe are from
last year. So for a one-bedroom at the
60% AMI level, that translates to a rent
of $1,417.
At the 80% AMI level, that's $1,890.
And then if we're looking at a
three-bedroom unit, um 60% AMI is 1,965.
And at 80% AMI, it's 2,621.
>> And to provide some context, this is
probably the most stark, but for a
three-bedroom unit, there's, mind you,
there's only a handful in this
neighborhood, but the current going rate
for a three-bedroom unit market rate
exceeds $3,300.
And the 60% unit, three-bedroom units of
this property will rent for under
$2,000. So that's the starkkest example
of course um but you know there there is
a that there is a third party um report
that was conducted on y'all's behalf um
that is required under the law as well
and I think the you know the rent
reduction alone was somewhere in the
ballpark of you know 2.5 to $3 million
over like a 10-year horizon. Um and so
obviously things change, market
conditions change. hopefully supply will
continue and rents will continue to go
down and maybe I don't know if that's
going to happen but um there is there is
that rent benefit and again not only is
the rent restriction in place but the
fact that it's income restricted means
that just because I make more money
doesn't mean I can take advantage of
that lower you know if that market rent
happened to go down I can't take that
unit away from someone who falls below
that threshold and that's part of the
problem too. In housing, we often have
filtering where, you know, the the
highest income earners will take that
nicest apartment, which and then it just
trickles down and you continue to move
down the totem pole. So, in this case,
this is going to be the nicest
apartment, and half of them will be for
those at those levels. It will be
restricted to them. Uh, you know, it's
not, hey, we can't find someone, we'll
just put someone in there, you know. No,
we it has to be, you know, it has to be
reserved for for folks making it at
those levels.
>> And you just said something that
reminded me also again for benefit of of
our newer members. So, um, all of the
units will be equipped
exactly the same, right? So, it's not
like there's nice units with granite
countertops and those are the market
rate units. Um, everybody's going to
have the the same unit finishes, the
same access to amenities. Um, so that's
I think really important also is that
it's not like, okay, well, yes, you have
really nice apartments for the market
rate folks and then not so nice ones for
the the restricted.
>> It's the same building, right? You know,
and and we've seen that, you know, there
a lot of critiques of programs in other
states where
>> there was different doors.
>> I was going to say the poor door.
>> The pore door, right?
>> The poor door. I'm not a big fan of the
pore door.
>> Yep. And so, not only is the same unit
finishes, but you said it right, but
access to amenities. There's no
additional, oh, you want to use the
pool, you have to pay us $100. You know,
there's that's not allowed. It's not
allowed under your terms in the lease
and and and it will never be allowed at
this project. You will not know if if
your neighbor is in a 60% unit or your
neighbor's in a market rate unit. You
would never know.
>> That's right. And then so I do think
just one other thing that I just wanted
to to touch on um based on on your
question director is that um and we I've
talked about this and I wish that we had
maybe scheduled the workshop today but
it would have just been made for a very
long meeting but I think with these
projects you have to think about it in
terms of like there's these different
levers right that you can pull and when
you pull one lever you're going to push
another lever in in the opposite
direction. And so that's what some of
the things that Nick was talking about
with respect to keeping the project
financially viable. If we're going to
ask for deeper affordability, then we
have to give on something else, right?
Which might be the fact that it can't
have structured parking. It's going to
be surface parked or the fact that, you
know, we can't have as much green space,
right? So those are and those were
things that we talked about um, you
know, at length in our previous meetings
was, okay, what are your priorities? And
you can take project by project and say,
"Okay, we really want to focus on super
deep affordability on this this piece of
land that we have or that we have access
to." And so let's look at the best not
only structure in terms of the physical
structure of the the project, but also
the financial structure. And as I
mentioned at the beginning, that's the
only subsidy that this project receives
as a property tax exemption. If we're
looking to do that really deep
affordability, the best program for that
is the low-income housing tax credit
program that has a lot of subsidies that
come into it from the the federal level
and the state level. So, that's a way
for you to to engage in or to um I think
the right word is is is to um
incentivize that type of of development
would be through that program because
you're going to be able to keep as many
amenities and as many levers pulled
towards your direction because you have
that additional subsidy in there. But if
we were to ask for 30% AMI units or 50%
AMI units on this project, number one,
I'm not even sure that it would have
been possible given the challenging um
capital markets right now, and when Nick
said deals aren't closing. Deals are not
closing, right? Like it is a very
challenging time right now, not only in
Austin, but across the state, um deals
are just not able to make the capital
markets were spooked by multiple things,
not only at the federal level, but also
at the state level. Um but we would have
to have given on a lot more of those
levers. And so based on what the
priorities were that were stated, you
know, priorities of the district at the
time that were stated, that was the
reason that we talked about keeping the
affordability where it was number one
because it it met the teachers and and
the district um demographics, but also
because there were a lot of other
priorities that were met by this
project. And I will just add I also do
low-inccome housing tax credit projects.
I know some of you have had a chance to
see some of them beautiful projects. And
if there's a future where this PFC wants
to look at other opportunities to do
something like that, I will be first in
line raising my hand to to partner with
y'all. So it it is a unique and separate
program. Um again with a ton of federal
subsidy in the tunes of tens of millions
of dollars unlike this which is
completely private capital that's being
invested. So
>> there was one more thing on Mr. Tovar's
question. Director Tovar's question was
huge. Um and Nick you did mention this
so you might just want to mention it
again. Uh you mentioned the one to one
was it one to one uh market to
affordable that the market actually
subsidizes the affordable.
>> Correct. So the as Summer was saying the
only direct subsidy is the fact that the
property the project does not pay
property taxes. Well, right now the
property doesn't it's exempt anyway
because it's been a school for since
1956. Um, but that being said, because
of that, you're taking one of your
largest operating expenses out of the
capital stack, which allows you to be
able to have a larger mortgage on the
property. So, that's how you make it
work. And so, those market units then
are able to subsidize those lower units
and together you can cover the debt on
that larger mortgage that you're able to
obtain. And so that is the subsidy here
on the line tech on the low-inccome
housing tax credit program. There's also
a property tax exemption. But then
instead of getting equity where the
investor needs to make a return, a
riskadjusted return better than the
stock market, better than something
else, it's not it's not the same. You're
getting credits from the federal
government that actually subsidize the
the overall cost of the project. So two
very unique programs. Um not to get
political, but in Texas, I wish we had
more programs. Other states have pots of
funding at the state level to invest in
workforce housing and to be creative. We
don't. We have this tool and that's it.
And we're able to be creative with it
and get in this instance uh you know
it'sund and you know it's it's 150 units
that are going you know that are going
to be rent and income restricted. So
>> thank you. uh other directors
>> I do I have I'm kind of like director uh
Tovar I can hear the questions already
mine is particularly on construction
Nick you said November 20th is when you
are when NRP is looking to break ground
and start construction
>> that that we will have the financial
closing on November 20th. So, at that
point, we will enter into a ground
lease. Um, we will close on the
construction loan and all that. In terms
of actually mobilizing the new
construction piece, because mind you,
we're out there right now doing
demolition and abatement. In terms of
mobilizing the new construction portion
of this once we close, there there's a
little bit of a lap sometimes with the
city of Austin. We need to get they
literally stamp plans and had to do all
that. They had to go out. There's
environmental inspection. Tree
protection needs to go up. That's
extremely important, especially at a
site like that, like this property. So,
within a few within, I would say within
30 days of November 20th, it will be a
full-on construction site.
>> Okay. Uh, also, congratulations on
getting those permits worked out with
the city. I was part of those
conversations and we weren't even having
these meetings yet. Um, but I'm just I'm
thinking about the community that lives
there. Are we being intentional with
letting them know um when construction
is happening? I've been to the community
meetings, not all of them, um, but I see
residents attending these meetings. I
have not seen the local business owners
that I know personally uh, in that area
attend these meetings. I just think, you
know, we we need to
really make the community aware, hey,
this is starting. It impacts it's a
domino effect, right? It doesn't just
impact the people living there, but the
people getting to work in the businesses
in that area.
>> That's a absolutely fantastic point. So,
you know, it's going to be a
construction site and and and and that's
as all you know, that's a mess and and
so what we've done to this point is we
have had signage out the property, you
know, QR codes. We've canvased the
neighborhood, including the businesses.
is I wish the business owners would
attend like you said because I think
they'd be great word of mouth frankly to
their customers coming. So maybe we can
if especially if you have personal
relationships maybe I can enlist you to
assist in that. But we have built up a
pretty significant um interest list. Um
and I would say it's probably half
neighborhood residents, half people, you
know, teachers, staff, folks that have
heard about this and been interested. We
did, for example, before we started the
environmental remediation and
demolition, we held a webinar exclusive
to that uh where really a lot of
residents showed up because like wanted
to let them know, hey, you're going to
start seeing activity at the site. A lot
of them had questions. At this point in
time, a lot of people have my cell phone
number. We do have my personal cell
phone number. We also have a dedicated
project phone line for this that's also
posted at the site. When more fencing
things goes up, we'll do more banners
about that. But the idea is when we get
into the thick of construction, if
there's going to be a road closure, if
there's going to be things like that
that are going to impact nearby
residents, we want to make sure people
know ahead of time so that they can plan
accordingly. Are we going to be able to
avoid that altogether? Never. But can we
at least try to be proactive?
Absolutely. So, we will continue to use
that existing list serve. We'll continue
to use the website, but we'll probably
start to, you know, we'll probably
canvas the neighborhood again like, hey,
sign up here to know, you know, to know
about road closures. And that's what we
did is we went door to door for those
homes and businesses that are directly
in that walking distance of the site.
But that that is a great point and I
want to make sure we you know try to
mitigate those concerns as much as
possible because there will be pouring
foundations, you know, in Texas where
it's really really hot. You have to pour
those foundations in the middle of the
night and that's all you can do and
that's how construction works and that
will take place for a good, you know,
handful of days. But if we can warn
folks ahead of time to expect that, you
know, maybe they it can help ease those
concerns. Yeah, there are some
businesses in East Austin that have
employees showing up at, you know, 3 or
4 a.m., too. So, it's, you know, it's
going to be around the same time. You
know, I think it's it's important. I do
think just being proactive, you know,
about it, too, is important, too. It is
again a domino effect, right? It's
people coming in to work at these
established locations. So, uh, Nick, we
are going to do a foot on the ground
work.
>> Absolutely.
>> We're going to go have all the coffee
dates there. So I do want to I do want
us to be mindful of it. Yeah,
>> thank you. Very good point.
>> Uh you answered my question about the
par of all, you know, that the units are
indistinguishable depending on their
affordability. So, that was, you know,
something we really appreciated and
valued, especially, um, I'll let the
other directors know, we had the chance
to tour a property, um, that was built
by the same developer, and it was really
helpful to see a real building and how
that worked. So, that was very nice.
>> You'll see a real building in about two
years.
>> Yeah. But, but it was helpful to see a
real building you had already made.
>> A new real building.
>> Yes. A new real our real building. Yeah.
With you. So, um, and I also just wanted
to share appreciation for Director Tovar
having this vision a very long time ago
and not giving up on the district while
we caught up. Took a long time. Um, but
I think you were the spark. You know,
you and a lot of people in the
neighborhood did a lot of work to spark
this and uh, really excited about all
that's ahead of us. So, thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you, Director Boswell. It means a
lot to me and uh you know coming from
you who's you know championed you know
so much for the district and these kids
and the families. Thank you and staff um
and trustee Hunter I mean director
Hunter still learning the words.
Director Gonzalez
>> we are too.
>> We are still
>> um not only on the board but also in in
classrooms. Um and also and thank you uh
Mr. Walsh um and summer for your um
thorough explanations and all of your
thorough work and thinking about all the
different aspects, you know, and trying
to be as as gentle as possible in your
approach. And I also would just think to
um this I this um
you know thought from 2013 came more to
target families to like support families
staying our our historic families in at
Go Valley um east side which was at the
Johnston campus at that time you know
and supporting them I know it can be
really tough now that you're talking
about you know all of the market um
information that you've you know um
explained so great. Um
I also want to think about how like when
we talk about staff and teachers, their
families and their kids and them being
able and and feeling like we're thinking
about their kids going to go valley
across you know a block a couple blocks
away. So something to think about too.
>> Hi thank you everyone for your comments.
I do have one question that I think
might be appropriate for a brief
executive session if that's okay. Yeah.
Okay.
>> Okay.
Who needs to come with us?
>> Um who who Okay. Um I'm going to do this
on the fly because we don't have any
sort of thing. Uh now do I have endings
for the for exec section? I don't have
one. There's supposed to be a lot of 55.
Can I move for a brief executive
session?
>> I think that's what we're gonna have to
do,
>> Kenneth Summer. You know,
>> to get clarification on what we're about
to approve.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, that's what I'm looking for. The
555s. That's that's what I'm looking
for. And I don't have those.
>> It's not in this. It might be, but it's
not in this one.
>> Well, I don't have my phone, so send it
to one of the other directors. Here we
go.
>> Okay, here we go. Oh, thank you.
>> Thank you. Excellent.
>> Awesome. Excellent.
All right. Um,
we're now going to take a brief uh
executive to go out to exe excuse me,
out to executive session to uh consult
with legal counsel um
>> pardon
>> or board or board counsel um
in accordance with chapter 551 of the
Texas government code section 551.071551
071 551.072
551.073
551.087
551.076
551.129
and 551.071.
Thank you. We will return and then uh
adjourn.
>> Thank you so much. Uh we are returning
to the open meeting at 6:53
p.m.
Um and uh we've received uh advice from
our council. We are still at the portion
where directors are asking questions and
comments.
>> Hi, thank you. Um, so my question was
about some of the language I guess that
was at the end of the agenda item
posting below the table. Um, where you
talk about some of the benefits to AISD
employees that might be applying to um
to live in the the complex and uh how
the deal affects their application fee
or the background check fee. Um, and I
guess my question would be if there is
an opportunity to expand that
consideration to not only apply to AISD
employees but also to AISD families and
if that consideration were to be
included at this point, what the
consequence of of considering something
like that might be.
>> I
I think that's a great idea. Um,
so there's two pieces of it. So there's
the preferred employer which is the
waving of the fees which are referring
to um
I have to get back to you on the
mechanics of it. I am not opposed to
that at all. We have done preferred
employers with all in all kinds of
cities with different things and so I
think it's similar. I just you know with
the preferred employer we we receive
payubs so it's very easy. So it's like I
don't know do you bring in your son's
report card? Maybe I you know maybe
that's what it is and we can figure that
out. I I think we could figure that out.
I I don't see a reason why we couldn't
figure out a way to do that. Um so that
AIST families have that benefit as well.
>> I don't know if council had anything to
offer.
>> I don't have anything else additional.
>> I I think that's a really good idea. I
just want to say because again that's
you know it was part of the early
conversations were also not just about
serving teachers and staff but about
also keeping families in these
neighborhoods in these communities where
they've been pushed out of these
communities and so part of the reason
why the school facility you know had to
shut down in the first place.
>> Thank you. I I appreciate that and it
was really trying to build on some of
the comments that were made by Director
Tovar. Um, and if that possibility does
exist in fact for um,
the east wing of this complex, I'd be
very much interested in exploring that
at this time. And if it doesn't, given
the the constraints and some of the
challenges that you mentioned earlier
about continuing on with the deal um, at
the very least expanding that
consideration to to the west. That's my
personal preference. I'm not sure how
other director
>> No, I I think I mean I don't want to
back myself into a corner. I think we
could figure out how to do that. I don't
think that's going to be prohibitive by
any means. And so I it I will take this
back to the management team and we can
figure out how to we get this in east as
well.
>> Thank you. That's that's the only
question concern I had. Thank you.
>> Anyone else?
Okay.
>> My I'm so sorry. Secretary Boswell, do
we have a motion to approve agenda item
2.3?
>> Yes. Yes. I move to approve item 2.3
resolution authorizing the Anita Koy
Apartments East transaction. Is there a
second? Second.
Directors. Any further comments or
questions on that part? Okay. Having a
motion by Secretary Boswell and a second
by Director Gonzalez to approve item
2.3, resolution authorizing Anita Koi
Apartments East Transaction. All those
in favor, please raise your right hand.
Excellent. The motion passes
unanimously.
Thank you everyone. This concludes our
meeting.
Excellent. Secretary Boswell, one more.
Secretary Boswell, do I have a motion to
adjourn the meeting?
>> So moved.
>> The meeting is adjourned at 657.
Good job, everyone.